hello everybody and welcome to episode
number 11 of my road to one bill series
today we're starting off with just
getting a attack level so we have the
requirements now to go into the Warriors
Guild uh which will be exciting so we
can get the defender main focus of this
episode though is going to be range as
well as
Slayer okay so we can actually finally
upgrade our Cape slot so we can get the
obsidian Cape um because you just look
like such an idiot without a cape
unfortunately like look at that look at
that
look look like a stupid person and now
look great there we go uh so we have an
extra 10 or 20 defense um from the cape
and uh yeah I think we might go try and
get our Defender okay we're at the
Warriors Guild guys this is exciting
finally can get in here so as far as I'm
aware the best way to get the the entry
tickets coins tablets whatever they're
called is to just um a [__] we forgot
our armor okay there we go we're back
and yeah the best way is just to fight
the these reanimated armor sets I'm
doing mythal right now I'm not sure what
the most efficient one is uh but I don't
seee to have any problems killing this
mythal armor set you just do it for a
few minutes and you get enough tokens to
go into the top level to fight the
cyclopses okay so we got about 325 uh
coins whatever these things are and yeah
we'll fight the cyclopses hopefully we
get a couple of our Defenders I'm not
sure if we're going to do the whole
grind all at once um but we'll slowly do
it to get our Dragon Defender over the
next couple days okay there is our
bronze Defender uh took about uh 12 15
minutes uh it's not too bad and now
we're just about to get a defense level
uh we're running out of tokens so we're
going to leave for now uh we only got
the bronze Defender so far uh but we are
getting very good defense experience
there's level 50 defense and uh yeah
steady progress okay guys we're actually
about to hit a farming level we're just
hit 50 farming and that only from rard
we haven't done any trees since the very
beginning so if you're just doing these
runs you're farming level steadily goes
up and it's just nice for quests or
diary requirements um cuz farming does
take a while if you had to grind it all
at once for something but over the
course of a couple months we're barely
doing it it's really not too bad okay
there is our iron Defender uh we went
back and got another 300 tokens um so
we're kind of kind of at a steady rate
not too unlucky not too lucky so far um
but yeah there's our iron Defender okay
just as I say that we got our steel
Defender about uh 5 minutes later only
50 tokens really used uh so that kind of
Lucky so we're going to take a break
from that grind for a little while and
uh our compost potions that we've been
buying for the last couple days finally
come through uh they're coming through
pretty much the max that they can 50
every 4 hours um I just kind of regret
doing this cuz combining them is
complete AIDS a bit uh I think if
actually combined 50 every time you
bought 50 wouldn't be so bad it only
take you like five five minutes to
combine 50 potions but when you have to
do all 500 at once it just takes a while
but um we have some rard we're going to
sell here for another 1.8 mil as well as
some air orbs we've charged we're
probably going to do a little bit more
of that as well um but for now today
we're mainly going to be grinding the
the archery the Archer
range range sorry and um yeah
unfortunately I lost a couple clips for
this episode so I made a lot of progress
but um some of the clips got lost I'm
going to try to fix that for next time
but hopefully you still enjoy it's going
to be lost Slayer and range but to start
off we're going to run some more air
orbs here um again we're wearing two
pieces of Grace FKS I just do not trust
I do not want to lose that and um we're
going to do another 500 orbs or so maybe
a th000 we'll see how we feel uh just
get about get again like 400 to 500k an
hour and about 40K magic experience so
not so bad there is some serious pking
going on at air orbs I do not know why
like it maybe they're trying to mess
with hardcore Iron Man because it
there's just no point like I'm going to
lose like Glory no no I'm not even lose
the glory I'm lose some air orbs and
they're going to get like an inventory
of air orbs or unpowered orbs it's kind
of dumb all right we're just about to
get a magic level I think that is uh 68
magic uh one more here and there we go
68 magic again we're going to eventually
go for 75 but uh it's nice getting a
magic experience where you're actually
making money okay so we sold off the
renards and the air or orbs uh one thing
I've also been mentioning or meaning to
mention is um some of you have been
asking what random items I might collect
or you could donate and I've decided on
blue feathers uh so I have about uh 20K
of them or something so far someone
generously donated me most of these
already um but yeah if you have any
spare blue feathers uh lying around or
you feel like doing some really shitty
farming uh you can get me some feathers
or you can buy them off the grand
exchange or or you just don't I don't
care but if uh that's your thing you can
give me some blue
feathers okay so we're going to finish
up our task of pyr fiends uh our goal
today is going to hopefully get our
Slayer to 55 because we're using mythal
darts and even sometimes Rune
darts so it is much more expensive the
broad bolts require 55 Slayer and
they're only like 60 each or something
but there we go we'll grab another task
our next task is going to be 12 Health
hounds that's actually pretty good I
think I can cannon that in ne's cave so
yeah we'll give that a shot okay so I
don't know why I'm lagging so bad but uh
here's the location I'm going to do it
in you can safe spot in this place I'm
failing to get to oh my God okay so we
decided to just uh range the hell hounds
that we couldn't really find a place put
our Cannon without kind of being a dick
so we decided to just uh rrange it
regularly for now until we find an open
world
and yeah we're about to hit 72 range
which is actually pretty nice that'll
only leave us with three more range
levels until we can use the
blowpipe um and we have gotten a couple
hard Clues from the hell hounds mind you
I don't have a lot of the quests to do
what
Bond yeah I was just chatting this guy
apparently he knows who I am oh I going
to no okay I'm going to redeem this
right away um it's not going to go
towards my account it's just going to go
right into my membership so let's just
be saving me money uh for any of you
saying I'm accepting donations uh I'm
not going to use this in in-game
currency I'm just going to Red redeem
this for membership right away but shout
out to this guy he actually just gave me
a bond for no reason which is awesome
kakos thanks man and there's 72 range uh
so yeah pretty nice actually okay and
just uh just to confirm this again I'm
Redeeming the bond right away I'm not
going to cash it in for any actual
in-game money even though I'm using a
monthly paid membership on this account
uh an extra 14 days is awesome so
unfortunately this is one of the places
where I lost quite a bit of footage U
we're at 73 range getting pretty close
to 74 now and 51 Slayer we did um
hellhound task we did a lesser demon
task we did a couple other shitty ones
um but now we're going to take a break
and we're going to try killing other our
chaos DS again it's late at night
hopefully we don't get
pked and yeah we'll give it a shot okay
just as much of a cluster [__] as I
remember uh but haven't been killed so
far which is nice uh we're still getting
about 90 to 100K XP an hour in range uh
it's pretty good okay so we didn't die
the first trip uh we used about 500
Canon balls mind you that only takes
about 15 minutes so we may have just
locked out there but we're just going to
keep doing this until I die pretty well
uh it's not for the money it's just for
the experience so whatever all right and
here it comes I'm getting pked there's
just no way to get out of here like
watch I'm just about to get out and then
just bam teleport right the [__] back in
oh
yeah ah God damn it I wish there was a
way to Juke around here but I'm just so
dead I hate the Wilderness okay so uh
we're not going to do that anymore we're
continuing on my Slayer we're going back
to infernal Mages now someone in the
clan chat told me that was actually
their friend who P me so fair game but
ah I
just can I just please do that for an
hour straight without dying wow I got a
Mystic hat actually from these guys
sweet 11k whatever let's just equip it
instead dude this hat looks so much
sicker okay there's level 52 Slayer now
we can kill jellies which is a kind of
decent task I guess okay and that is the
last infernal Mage I would not recommend
this task unless you had to they're
pretty accurate and they attack uh for
like hit fives and sixes a lot with
magic uh but there we go 10 more points
and we'll grab another Slayer task okay
let's give us something good this time
and Rock Rock
slugs okay so we finished up our task of
rock slugs using The Good Old brind
Saber cuz uh I am not using the bags of
salt on these guys and uh there we go
that is 27 tasks in a row and we'll go
ahead and grab another one okay let's
get something good this time it's going
to be a cave slimes it's not very good
but I can do it in probably 10 minutes
so not too bad okay I cannot say I can
remember this wall ever raping me like
that
before but uh okay that was kind of
weird okay we finished up our task of
cave slimes and now we have [__] Tres
and they're not awful but I think we're
going to take a little break from Slayer
and uh go grind out a Defender a little
bit more okay so we're just going to
[__] a little bit of tokens but as
we're doing that we actually got a
defense level so there's 54 defense um
which is quite a bit higher than that
was last time but again we lost some
clips um part of those we did get some
defense experience as well and 78 combat
as well so we're kind of getting up
there okay there's level 55 defense so
we kind of missed it um but there we go
55 defense and we got a steel Defender
as well uh just catching up on what you
may have missed and yeah let's continue
on with the Cyclops grind there is our
black Defender uh only took another 20
minutes or so so we're not getting too
unlucky actually actually relatively
lucky um and it doesn't feel so bad
doing this like spread out over the
course of a couple days grinding all at
once can feel like quite a while but um
not too bad we're on a black Defender
already okay there's the mythal defender
that was quite quick so I'll say that
was lucky for sure um but we we have
only 170 tokens left so we'll see if we
can actually get any more Defenders with
what we have left okay so unfortunately
this is the other part where my recorder
decide to just explode unfortunately uh
we got to 74 range and we're getting
very close to 75 as well as we're
extremely close to 55
Slayer um we just did a bunch of tasks
we had a greater demon task we had a
lesser demon task and we spent about 1
milon cannonballs uh so that's kind of
what you guys miss pretty well okay so
we're on our jelly task and we are just
about to hit 55 Slayer now we can start
using the broad bolts cuz right now
we're using runite uh which is very
expensive and there we go that is 55
Slayer we can now kill turos and use the
broad bolts uh so like I was saying I
did lose quite a bit of my footage so
this is probably going to be it it's
pretty late at night we're going to get
this range level and then we're probably
go and edit this uh before it explodes
anymore um but I hope you guys
understand if it does end up being
shorter it might not be sometimes really
that adding up the clip lengths um but
there we go there is 69 hit points all
right guys we are back and we are about
to hit that range level we've been
working towards for about a week now but
hit 75 range and with it we can finally
use the toxic blowpipe our plans for
that is going to be barrows uh zra
eventually and actually if we want to
train in Nightmare Zone um the toxic
blowpipe is a very good option as well
so there's 75 range finally can equip
the blowpipe and I think that's where
we're going to call it for today guys I
hope you did enjoy uh if you did uh toss
video like and remember to say
subscribed uh for when the next episode
comes out all right I'll see you guys
next time
[Music]